hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot's
III demo stage I'm your host Mike
McCarty here with Nick margarita hey
how's it going guys and we are joined by
two producers from FIFA 18 Aaron McCarty
and Matt Prior hey how you guys doing
good happy to be here talk about the
game yes I clean up us we saw a little
bit about FIFA 18 at EA's press
conference Saturday yeah so we had a few
questions we wanted to ask regarding a
few of the things that you know what
you're doing going into the next year I
think my main like broader question is
what were your goals going from FIFA 17
to 18 what were things you want to
change what are like some big objectives
you had with the game I guess like
speaking broadly okay yeah I think
there's a number of things always we
listening to our fans and listen to the
feedback we got so there was some things
that we definitely wanted to improve
upon in gameplay and gameplay was a
massive focus for us this year we
obviously are in second year of
frostbite which is which is a really
cool thing for us because really coming
through our own or making the game look
and feel spectacular so when you look at
the feature set that we had in gameplay
this year focusing on the player the
teams and the atmosphere a lot of that
is stuff that we really feel like this
year versus last year were able to
really harness and and some of the
things you're seeing inside the stadiums
with the regionalization that we're
doing and what we're doing the crowds
and the lighting is really starting to
make that that that environment come to
life for those dramatic moments did you
talk about the crowds and lighting
because that was like seemed like a
pretty like a big focus right during the
beginning of that reveal right stuff
like you want to get the atmosphere of
these separate crowds whether you're at
like a Premier League game or La Liga or
something like that you talked about
that yeah I mean crowd is a massive part
of football you know in a somewhat
biased opinion we think it's the best
sport in the world and won it one of the
reasons for that is the atmosphere it
generates there's no atmosphere like the
atmosphere at a football football match
and that varies the world over a game in
South America is very very different
from a game in the EPL is to get that
kind of uniqueness and that flavor that
that's different all over the world so
we really wanted to bring that to the
game so this is where the region
regionalization came in so a good
example is La Bombonera in South America
if you play a game now in FIFA there
versus EPL you'll notice massive
differences from the lighting obviously
the lighting varies from around the
world and then the crowd behavior is a
big one and then just just elements that
are unique to south american games
that pitch litter you'll get that
sideline props all these little things
which overall make for the the kind of
the the major atmosphere so we've
tweaked all that so now there's a big
variation depending on where you play
and that is part of the kind of DNA of
football so that's why we want to kind
of bring it to FIFA right Nick you
played FIFA 17 a little bit with Alex
hunter playing in the Premier League yep
four he moves over but I know a lot of
fans are looking forward to seeing that
story kind of continue yeah I know you
guys did a little bit of a tease
at the EA press conference could you go
into kind of where's this story headed I
know you can't tell that about I'll tell
you basically the basics LA Galaxy
carpet in the locker room at the end of
that right right wait just go in a
pre-season tour of the beginning okay
involves the LA Galaxy we can argue that
much yeah there's one of those modes
where we can't reveal too much because
we don't want to give a spoilers away
what we can say is that as a game we
represent the world of football the
world over and as you mentioned the last
one was focused on the EPL but this time
we want to kind of broaden the horizons
of the game and and you know let Alex
spread his wings a little bit I'll be
kind of a gaz that so there will be some
bait major changes in Alex's life there
will be some yeah there'll be some big
decisions he has to make and we just
wanted to build a bigger and more
celebrity cast as well so some of the
moments that really resonate in the last
one is when you interact with real-world
players and that's understandable you
live in the dream of being a real world
footballer so that connection with
DeMaria Harry Kane that kind of thing is
it really popped for users so we've kind
of double down on that so you'll see a
lot more celebrity and a lot more real
player interaction again I don't want to
really want to spoil it too much I can
say you meet Ronaldo and get to interact
with the Ronaldo okay and because that
is reasonably early on but yeah there's
a lot of big changes we've added local
multiplayer which is again some of the
feedback we got from fans and you don't
have to commit to that at the very
beginning you can do it on a match by
match basis so unique and now players
players hunter players team or
multiplayer and that's going down really
well and then we like to say we've got
some big decisions in there but one of
the cool things is you can now customize
Alex hunter so your hunter is very
unique to you so we saw millions of
YouTube videos are around the journey
all of those look the same because you
can really vary hunter now there's going
to be uniqueness to those because you
can give him a
crazy Pogba style haircut or tattoos or
all his clothing is interchangeable so
that's another kind of nice element that
we can have added on to get like sec to
keep give your hunter a little bit of a
uniqueness so when you introduce the
jury in FIFA 17 it's interesting to see
you know Madden announced their longshot
mode with Madden 18 and you have an NBA
Live 18 doing the one which both seem
more like you know character focus and
kind of there's a narrative to it like
can you talk about like seeing that kind
of story driven sports game emerging
like it's not like we haven't had these
kind of sport games for a long time yeah
I think you know when we look at the
large number of players that play FIFA
every year there's a different type of
player for a different type of mode and
we want to make sure that we create
something for everybody in our game so
that's why last year when we brought the
journey and we really felt like we were
building an experience for a subset of
fans that wanted an immersive style
experience following that one character
having a story being told to them so we
wanted to be able to make sure that that
that we had that offering in our game
because it was kind of a space that was
missing from the types of modes that we
were making in our game obviously FIFA's
a very vast game in terms of the depth
of all of the things that we're doing
from Ultimate Team to the journey to to
our online modes to career mode we got a
whole lot of stuff in there so I think
it was just we felt like there was one
desire of our fans that we could still
meet with a mode like the journey and
again obviously we're doubling it down
this year bringing you the journey too
and I feel that our brothers and Madden
and and MBA sort of have the same
philosophy that that following that
single character is is a motivator for
some of our fans I think it's a sad a
sport that is much more prevalent these
days I mean the world of social media
really get a window into footballers
lives and what they're doing like never
before so I think we've always done a
great job of focusing on the 90 minutes
off the pitch so this really gave us the
opportunity to kind of go behind the
curtain and see the life of a
professional football and it's very
authentic we went out to talk about a
lot of real-world pros so it's great to
get that feedback that what we
ultimately delivered was very authentic
and it resonated with people and the
other great thing about the journey is
it's great gateway into into FIFA if
you're not a massive football fan it's a
great way to engage with the game learn
a little
about the culture and while you do that
you then come out the other side of it
knowing the game mechanics we always
kind of pictured is a little bit like
basic training for FIFA because what
we've seen in the past is a lot of users
great get fee for they hero it's a great
social game there's a great online
community they dive into online without
really being ready and knowing the
fundamentals of the game lose ten mil
and it ceases to be much fun so the
journey is a great gateway into both the
culture of football and also the
gameplay mechanics yes outside the
journey and outside like just you know
like the modes like my multiplayer modes
you talk about like are you talking more
about any changes you're making to other
modes so we're not talking about what
we're doing in career mode at this point
although there is a little bit of subset
of some of the things that we're doing
in game play having a massive impact on
career mode we've done a lot of work on
the team elements of gameplay with a new
positioning system and also trying to
make team styles come to life a little
more in the game by making the great
teams that you know like Barcelona
Barcelona play ticky-tack a footballer
and and having the catenaccio style
Italian defense where you sit back and
wait for that opportunity to
counter-attack so getting more of these
team styles into the game through the
technology that we've been putting in
and in our positioning system in our CPU
AI system has actually had the massive
benefit that in career mode when you're
playing match to match to match against
the AI you're getting a lot of variety
and the games of feelings different from
week to week and you're starting to feel
that the character of those teams that
you're playing against come to the
forefront the other mode big mode that
we are not talking about really right
now is ultimate team we do have a ton of
cool things coming down the pipe for
Ultimate Team so say it's stay tuned for
that but the one thing we are talking
about in Ultimate Team is we have icons
this year which are the world's great
greatest players of all time coming to
the game on all of our consoles on ps4
Xbox one PC and the first and only one
we're talking about right now is Ronaldo
Nazario which is Brazilian Ronaldo
alongside the christiana and all that we
have in the game and now I got a couple
of and all those will be will be
announcing some more icons I think today
day today talking about about four or so
more and then throughout the the
campaign to our launch you'll hear about
more of a
we're gonna have an ultimate team cool I
know a lot of people are going to be
really excited about that myself
included I think you guys have a really
big following for Ultimate Team so we're
pretty excited to see what kind of new
players are going to be in the game what
new features are being added so I feel
like you guys have been adding awesome
awesome like improvements every single
year for Ultimate Team as it develops
yep yeah I think we pleasantly surprised
when that information rolls out as to
what we've done this year which is kind
of in the run-up to games con so there
is a lot happening in there but yeah
we're not we're not talking about that
here unfortunately but rest assured you
you'll be pleasantly surprised I think
cool well Aaron Matt thank you so much
for coming on our stage problem and good
luck with the rest of the show thanks
everybody
watching from home if you're watching
our game spot III stage we'll have demos
from a bunch of games coming on
throughout the week here we'll have a
co-op stage downstairs we'll have press
conferences coming throughout the week
if they haven't ended by the time you're
watching this but in the meantime stay
tuned for more on FIFA 18 we'll be
covering and we'll see you then